you have created all these iconic
characters but you've also had an
extraordinary illustrious career and i
remember going to that premiere of year
of the dog and i did see a shift in your
performances and your intentions
did you ever feel like i have more than
the comedy inside of me and i'd like to
explore that yes i i did know that and
i'm so grateful to mike white because i
felt like he did give me that
opportunity to write something a little
more dramatic
and dark and sad and and that character
and year of the dog and so i i i do
credit mike with giving me that break
then where people were like oh she could
do drama you know that kind of thing who
then you also
recently did the white lotus
which is literally one of the most
well
good
did you love it are you
is there
does the next season have are you i'm
not in the next season no no no i'm
sorry this is not good this is not the
news i wanted they're shooting in sicily
right now mike's in sicily jennifer cool
just returning but then it's an all-new
cast and it'll be like you know a whole
different
different different hotel did you notice
how
freaked out everyone is and is
responding now to your dramatic acting
oh yes i mean it's like you whatever
niche you wanted to carve out for
yourself back in the day like you're
there people see you in both
comedy and drama and there's a reason
those two faces are
connected in the
arts or whatever you want to call it
because maybe one cannot exist without
the other is that the point of the
comedy and tragedy yes phases yes that
is so true because you have to yes yes
and can you turn your trauma into
something funny can you is there the
hope of recycling it into something that
does bring joy to everyone i think so
because i feel like that's what i did i
feel like i poured my feelings and art
into the characters before i was really
piecing it together it was coming
through in the work and you know i was
very physical i did characters who kick
and you know my dad had a brace on his
leg it's no accident that i'm doing
these characters that like can my dad
was limited physically he had a limp but
my characters all have an urge to like
break out and kick kick kick or walk
fast or they're you know like they have
this physical ability and i and i made
it physical and it was kind of like my
wish for my dad to like kick the braces
off his legs you know that's so powerful
yeah yes there's a story that really
speaks to me um
your dad came to snl and it was a
mother's day special yeah what was that
experience like snl does a sweet thing
where lauren michaels does a yearly show
with the customers get to invite their
mothers and it's so sweet you guys have
probably seen that right yeah and it's
become like a big deal but i was um i
had done the show for six seasons and i
was leaving
um but i didn't want to miss that
mother's day special well the one was
like it's fine just come back for the
mother's day special and i was like but
is it okay if i bring my dad
because you know my mom died he was like
yeah bringing your dad can be your mom
and maya rudolph also lost
her mom that's right and so anyhow she
brought her dad so basically my dad
loved it it was so fun having him go
through the ropes and they had the
parents do like a song and dance number
and my dad got to go through you know
hair and makeup and the wardrobe and
remember you know doing a little sketch
and he was like oh my god this is
exhausting he said i had no idea what
goes into this boy people don't know and
so it was just so special having him
there snl is like such a big deal it's
like the biggest most iconic institution
in the history of television but
is it true that by the way you got
mugged like after snl and like you were
what happened i had just auditioned for
saturday night live they put a bunch of
women up at standup new york and um
i had five minutes to do five characters
and i couldn't believe i was being flown
to audition for lauren michaels and
chris farley and and then i had a
wonderful meeting with lauren and then i
went to my sister's house to celebrate
and with her husband in um
tribeca and then i left and i was such
in such a good mood you know
hi hi and i got mugged in tribeca he
came and just like grabbed me and like
threw me down the ground and nobody was
around and it was very scary but i was
in such a good mood that i met lauren
that
i was like nothing's gonna get me down
you know and so um
he uh he he he just wanted money and so
i gave him my wallet and then um
he i was like do you want my coat and he
was like no that's okay you can keep
your coat and i was like oh he's so
sweet
just kidding
[Music]